[Music]
many had already been waiting before the
check-in desks opened these passengers
at manchester airport had been advised
by the airline tui to arrive extra early
so of course when you're waiting that
long is it when you're getting told to
come four hours and you haven't got the
tesla nice and poor on that
and then there were the cancellations
after we cleared up for so long we saw
the screen again and and it said
cancelled
we went and asked one of the touri
operators and we just said yes it's the
old holidays canceled
that's all we knew about it and
we're still in the dark now
tui has cancelled nearly 200 flights
from manchester over the next month it's
incredibly frustrating for many
passengers hoping to finally have a
summer holiday after staying home during
the pandemic
today these were the scenes from the
airport over the weekend police having
to tell holidaymakers headed for greece
that their flight had been cancelled
among those due to flight across was
liam west for a beachside wedding with
his partner kelly it's already been
pushed back three years because of covid
it was horrible
and obviously having to come home and
obviously we're up all night we just
obviously my partner was just crying all
the time i just didn't know what to do
they already have family out there and
other guests headed out this weekend
liam's mom amanda is one of them she's
distraught the wedding now can't go
ahead until july and she can't afford to
pay for the trip again
and i get upset myself
over it all why are you so upset
i just want them to be happy
i keep thinking it's not happening until
it's gotten down the aisle all the beach
from what they've always wanted
they've always wanted it
always
tui have apologized and blamed ongoing
challenges with their operation
they like other airlines are
experiencing staff shortages after
losing workers during the pandemic
easyjet and british airways have also
cut flights we've been saying to the
industry that they need to prepare for
this they need to have the staff that uh
that they need to make sure people can
get away and enjoy holidays there's been
many months where we've been back on the
the track particularly since the
vaccination to this moment and the
industry should have been recruiting
people
heathrow alone has 12 000 vacancies
including baggage handlers and security
staff but getting clearance to work
airside can take months as for the short
term it seems there's plenty more
disappointment to come for many hoping
to get away this week becky cottrell sky
news manchester